1000 gegner der einheit mich gesehen hab
ich gesehen hab ich gesehen hab ich
gesehen habe ich gesehen wie die wolken
geld geld geld geld geld wie ich kann
nicht einen schoko schoki ja ich werde
ihn schockiert oder habt ihr besseren
namen könnt ihr einfach mal in die
kommentare schreiben
die solche nennen das mammut hey leute
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
hero zusammen mit l p midcap hallo hallo
liebe freunde und es funktioniert wieder
gestern hat er nicht funktioniert und
jetzt ist er wieder am start des kev
kommt wieder server vom c wieder alles
ich bin gerade aus dem urlaub wieder
zurückgekommen kurzen ob ich war nicht
da deswegen auf die letzten von meiner
seite aus allein aufgenommen sorry dafür
perfekt es wird gerade tag alter bomben
hier übrigens ich habe in der letzten
folge einen killer bund geholt
eigentlich 200 heißt nämlich browser und
features die das die 102 kilo und es ist
ein wilder hund richtig geiler hund und
die heißen da oben ist ein vogel
einfuhren gesehen im achten stock dem
friedhof eigentlich verschönert hat ja
das habe ich beim alten manuel schon
gesehen dass die haben auch blümchen
hingestellt
das war alles nicht die haben gar nichts
gemacht weil ich ich hab den friedhof
komplett wales ist bastian komplett
aber ich verstehe dich capcom ich hab
zwei hunden und die haben eigentlich ein
kind gemacht und das habe ich in der
letzten folge gefragt wie die wie das
kind heißen sondern kampf will kommt
heran aber der hund ist jetzt weg
irgendwie weiß nicht ob ich den kader
benennen
damit nahm tag mit namensschildern aber
weil es ja noch gar nicht
aber weißt du ich habe jetzt einen
kleinen hund gehabt und diese die beiden
hier browsern petit sind mega sie kann
wie süß der eine sogar brauner der
anderes graue oder braune der braune
speed die braunen weil
frauen des ibykus männer
was liegt da erlebten grabstein mit
pizza abgebaut habe ich verstehe nicht
wusste der kleine kann ich den irgendwie
zu mir rufen oder so ich glaube wenn du
bisschen rum läuft müsste das doch zu
deportieren oder nie habe ich habe
gerade echt ehrlich gesagt angst nicht
dass ich den irgendwo so gewinnst hast
ihn hingesetzt das kann ja auch sein
das ist bitter natürlich das ist bitter
also ich kann ja mal erzählen was ich
gemacht habe wegen dessen du deine
umgebung sagt los ist ich war war sich
allein unterwegs war ich hätte auch
nicht gedacht dass das so einfach wäre
ich war in so einer burg gründe hat ein
spinnennetz gekillt und bin jetzt
praktisch voll equipped ich bin dort
auch bei sonderburg feinstem was mit dem
allerfeinsten chic belgique reifegrad
place an ok und place ist tot
ich dachte mir ich baue mir jetzt
einfach ein haus
oktober gar nichts drin in der kiste
nämlich wird geplündert ja das brot und
die seide drin ich glaube ich dass es
geplündert wurde weil das ist direkt am
zaun hier alles okay beide hunde haben
sich report aber der kleine nicht
ich hab so ein piratenschiff gefunden
erkennt der piratenschiff in rathenow
schiffe sind übel gut und es brennt was
das piratenschiff brennt ich habe nichts
gemacht es brennt einfach ist dann
eigentlich hätte der kleine hund ist
wahrscheinlich weg das heißt freunde
werden uns neues kleines männchen paaren
und zwar genau jetzt eigentlich hab gar
keine knochen ändern lassen wir das eben
ich wette das war ein blitz aber mir ist
auch schon aufgefallen es gibt ja so
eine region ist ja nicht um mittel
gelaufen oder ja genau ich bin auch eher
einmal weil ich das schon gestorben war
am anfang ein sportbad ich musste ja not
grund von der mitte zu unserem dorf
laufen mein gott das piratenschiff
brennt ab jump ist das denn wissen was
worauf ich hinaus wollte in der mitte
war irgendwo auf einer eisfläche auf wo
piraten schwerer niemand so ein gebiet
wo ich einfach von blitzen abgeschossen
wurde
einfach so es hat nicht gestimmt alter
aber dieses piratenschiffs die zu heftig
geil aus und vor allem ich weiß also
meine hunde sind jetzt wahrscheinlich
irgendwie die teleportieren sich wenn
ich übers wasser fahrer oder ja aber die
können abwinken scheiße
hunde sind blöd wenn er wenn ich doch
eher theoretisch mit dem boot rüber
fahren sollten sich doch erst
teleportieren wenn ich auf den
seite denn oder minijob orten sich
nonstop zu dass er auch jetzt posthum im
wasser ich möchte eigentlich ganzen
türme erstmal meiden bevor ich dann
wieder eine stadt kommt zu dir direkt
attacke man das ding ist hast du
eigentlich schon verzauberung stick oder
irgendwer
nee ich bin ja noch nicht mal einer
stadt gewesen ich bin der stadt gewesen
bin gestorben
dann bin ich wieder hier gesprochen dann
war die teleporter weg deswegen habe ich
jetzt so eine fette erkundung hinter mir
ach so dass man mir aus gewinnen zwei
folgen lang einfach schnurstracks in
richtung zu hause gelaufen und du hast
auf meinen kleinen schlenker gemacht wie
ich musste ich habe mehr oder weniger
ich konnte ja anders nicht zurück jetzt
hoffe ich in dem aber ich habe sehr viel
kraft blöd ich bin ich hab schon diesen
teleportieren zauberstab dass ich
fliegen kann killer kannst mir dass
eventuell mit zauberstäben ich wollte
eigentlich komme schon fragen aber immer
schon ein bisschen komisch
hier ist eine burg hier ist eine burg
hier sind in so eine burg wie im trailer
scheiße ich will ja gar nicht rein
genau da war ich denn da habe ich alles
gesammelt alter dass so eine burg also
ich habe eigentlich eine relativ gut
ausgerüstete hatten die giants wort und
was alles so schade meinte das ist
eigentlich schon damit das wort habe ich
auch ja ja genau da aber das ist ja mein
ressort operations zweifel gleichzeitig
durch weiß jetzt nicht ob das jetzt
angreifen oder nicht jungs dass wir auch
alle meint nicht soll das hier mitnehmen
diese blätter hier also es gibt so viele
sachen die ich selber noch nicht weiß
nicht weiß wie gesagt erst mal nur die
basics und weiß dass ich einfach nur ein
gelaufen bin
wir werden alles soll diese diese
blätter mitnehmen von diesem mal von
diesem namen berri weil die könnte ich
bei mir an pflanzen und da würden wohl
immer wieder melo berrys rauskommt die
könnte ich immer wieder essen das ist
eine unendliche fahre ja genau
davon gibt es einiges gehört nämlich
einfach mal mit hier danke übrigens dass
sie alle sagt hieß er den kommentaren
ich habe noch ein paar kommentare aus
fotografiert von euch die sehr nett und
sehr cool waren und sehr konstruktiv
aber ich werde da dran um mein gott
spawnen ja ganz viele leute um eckart
bohn so villiger mit rüstung und so ja
ja gar das richtige gegner also richtige
burg gegner aber die china nur um das
steht bisher nur um reifen nicht gleich
an
ähnlich klar da sind böse gegner bisher
machen die onyx wie er lässt aber nur
eine
und er ist noch ein eisbär ich hab grad
nur ein bisschen panik
der stark mir wurde von euch aber in den
kommentaren geschrieben dass ich
unbedingt ein piratenschiff suchen soll
aber ein klein ist weil in diesen
kleinen planstellen sollen verzauberung
tische seien und man kann völlig für lau
die zauberstäbe verzaubern mit amberg in
3 darauf bin ich jetzt ich laufe jetzt
suche ich sehe hier echt zu sachen ich
habe vor jedem konstruktion angst mehr
oder weniger die reinkommen hexel ich
habe einfach angst vor allem irgendwie
gerade weil das heft herrlich meine
stadt das müssen die einstellen
properties war jetzt völlig runter und
wenn ich jetzt sterbe dann gehe ich
durch das meiner besten bilanzen das
meinten die aber auch dass man nicht
sonst vorschlag machen soll das meinte
simon sogar er hat nicht verboten hast
du so ein ändert zauberstab und wieder
heißt ein das ist einfach unsere regeln
weiß auch nicht wie man sich so
stoßweise nach vorne
schubsen kann hier ist einfach so ein
haus das kann doch auch nicht sein hier
kann auch nicht einfach so ein haus drin
sein
wieder eine verliebte stehen jetzt bin
ich hier drin in dem haus ist aber
nichts ich will aber meine beiden hunde
ohne die beiden fühle ich mich nicht
sicher
fauser und peach vor seid ihr die
teleportieren sich und musste mir noch
mal was zeigen
das kannst du dir ich hab das border
gefunden oh mein gott ist ein zombie mit
rüstung nach einer gerechten ja noch ein
köcher weil es wird zwar schöne leiste
unten angezeigt wie viele links damals
hat sie viele pfeile aber irgendwie habe
ich gar keine okay wenn erst das bonner
den ich jetzt so aus nehme der sport
kaputt
und hier sind bücher 54 enchantment
bücher aber alles mit restauration 2 was
ich glaube es gibt ja auch andere zauber
sachen was ist restoration keine ahnung
system ist wir können ja nicht auf
deutschland gerade die verzauberung
tische sind so dermaßen verpackt hatte
ich herauskommen fangen die regeln
geschrieben das dann direkt dass spieler
warm up stützt ich komme ganz kurz nach
was respekt du hast ja hunde gefangen
ich sehe ja fuchs ja kann ich leben wir
sind ja nicht gleich runde habe ich den
namen ja ein steak isst seinen kameraden
auf atmung das heißt atmung das kann ich
mir wahrscheinlich auf dem helm drauf
machen kannst vielleicht unter wasser
arbeiten oder
schon ab ohne die wasserscheide bvb die
bremer mit
und was ist mit jasper blog jasper blog
ich weiß nicht ob das wertvolle sich mal
wenn das doch schon hier so einer kiste
drin ist ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal
mit den rettern finde ich echt so viel
und ich brauche gar kein redstone dass
hier immer ein bisschen runter schalte
bestimmt ist das total unnötig oha hier
schon wieder so eine heftige burg aber
er kämpfte ja normale burg gefunden
wahrscheinlich keine ahnung wie wahnsinn
im berg eingebaut da unten noch so ein
schaf von wegen aber hier ist seine
heftige burg ich hab noch nie seien
heftige burg gesehen junge aus schoko
busangebot ich wollte mein trikot holen
und den shocking
leute ich wollte mir echt also ein paar
tiere holen die ich dann immer so
sondern sonst bei mir auf machen mehr
oder weniger und hier sind richtig süßes
chocobos und umzu obus zu holen und aok
ich stehe in der mitte zwischen zwei
burgen junge das kann nichts gutes werde
ich schau jetzt mal ganz kurz in die
industrie herein aber die schokoprodukte
ich unten ist mir wieder ein boss aber
ich will nicht so ein riesenschiff ich
wollte aber keine riesenschiff ich
schaue einfach mal ganz kurzen diese
burg rein ich wette ich mache hier
gleich wieder irgendwas kaputt so dass
ich wieder sterben natürlich nicht sogar
da silva kisten von ich kann die kiste
aber ich bin ja ich sag dir das nicht
bau nicht einfach so an der seite in die
festungen rein ich jetzt ne cola coca
cola kisten ohne einen einzigen mob zu
besiegen hier ist ein killer kuh ich
empfehlen sondern ich will mich in seine
burg hallen bauen auf einmal ich drehe
mich auf einmal gucken
ich bin unter der ich bin unter der burg
ich bin in einem klassenraum drin ja
klasse
hier sind tisch und die sehen mich nicht
die gegner dass die kiste das aber
nichts drin ob ich der ich hoffe man
nicht dass die mich jetzt sehen
scheiße ich will eigentlich am liebsten
schnell weg scheuch ich zu euch nix die
turnier nix ich hoffe mal akzeptieren
dass jetzt diverse
die schoko feder
ich habe eine tokio feder das heißt wenn
ich jetzt eine trophäe habe sie ja aus
dem crafting table hin kommen dass hunde
so genau weißt du wie man diese
komischen team zählt oder was ja toko
was ist rokoko das satire du willst den
chocovic ihm aber weiß ich wieder heißt
ich gar keine schokolade 10
ich brauche leder er weißt du wie ich
wenn ich in ein rezept angezeigt habe
durch tun wenn die items wie ich das so
blass in meinen inventar reinkriegen
denn die in crafting apple keine ahnung
wie ich brauche dich brauchen leder
leder aber ich schmeiße jetzt einfach
mal weiß nicht ich den ersten block
wegschmeißen kannst du eventuell
schlagen kannst kannst du schlafen gehen
ich bin so dermaßen weit weg kannst du
dann eventuell gleich mal ganz kurz vom
server herunter gehen lasst mich kurz
vorm weißen rings wo kriegt in der 2
trinkt sehr alter aus was kriegt man
denn alles strings aus holz aus holz
eines tricks gedacht okay wartet bis
jetzt ein wetter doch was ja ich gehe
jetzt gerade ins bett ist das kalt die
ganzen mops die piraten die habe ich
ganz gut vom start war dann runter gehen
weil ich will ich nicht letzten aber
nicht dass jetzt gleich ganz viel spaß
im bett gut dauert nicht mehr lange ich
brauche unbedingt strings das heißt er
eigentlich kannst wieder drauf kommen er
heißt ja eigentlich dass ich will muss
ja aber wenn ich jetzt eine spinne oder
ich nehme einfach wolle von schafen und
darauf die staats wasserkopf noch gar
nicht gesehen kann ich nicht aus wolle
strings machen aber ich möchte jetzt ein
schoko hole mit dem nachhause reiten
aber wo meine hunde sind weiß ich auch
nicht die teleportieren sind wegen auch
schon weg das heißt haben die nicht mal
wasser teleportiert doch die
warentransport bei mir aber irgendwie
sind jetzt wieder nicht bei mir ich weiß
ich muss dir gleich noch suchen und das
gefühl du bist ein tier
freund ich brauche ich nicht nein diesen
blieb aber die teleroute diesen dummen
woche oder sind das da oben spinnens
ohne jacke kommen verpiss dich jetzt
hier turbo ich möchte einen anderen von
jutta feldmann detail hatten ihn
brauchst einfach und sattel du musst die
glücklich machen wie man diese mit einem
tanz mit dieser was ist größer
das ist so eine du kennst du dich erkenn
ich werde jetzt eine reihe gibt aus mit
den bürgern aus und dass ich ja
diamanten und ich habe einen körper kopf
auf wenn wir protection bringt da sind
mehr weiß nicht da sind gegner der
einheit mich gesehen dann hab ich
gesehen hab ich gesehen hab ich gesehen
habe ich gesehen wie dicht verfolgt wird
folglich geld geld geld geld geld geld
geld geld gelaufen bist okay sie sind
hinter mir schießt jetzt ab annas tod
einer sound der andere ist auch da und
beide todt ich filme gab von einem
piratenschiff aufs nächste beide tot
beide tot was kriege ich jetzt dadurch
nichts ein bisschen erfahrung natürlich
wie alle tot
da sagen wir eine gequälte scheiße dass
ein piratenschiff das und was die finde
ich unten
das einzige was ich finde ist eine
vergiftete potato alter herr bemühen ich
muss doch irgendwo sei der hier so viele
fledermäuse und mit einer schaufel
wieder mich verarschen
es behindert er kommt einfach mit einer
schaufel an der behinderung
ich möchte ich gar nicht so viel
erkunden aber allem einfach auf dem weg
ein bisschen danke ich muss doch
irgendwo eine spinne seien kriege ich
nicht aus wolle seide und man aber jetzt
sind ja gerade schon so viele schoko bus
das musst du eigentlich ausnutzen
ich hatte sogar dermaßen knapp mein
lieber drauf gegangen
hier muss doch irgendwo wolle sein ich
finde ich begreife es nicht hält das
verstehe ich gerade echt nicht so
langsam bin ich trau dich jetzt erst mal
wieder meine schere mit was kann ich
denn dafür wegschmeißen weil irgendwie
sind ja gar keine wirklichen scheffel
ich finde hier nur kacke sagt auf den
schipisten verzauberung fischer war noch
kein verzauberung fisch zu sehen
also was ich habe ich dachte ich hätte
10 von diesen mexikaner nicht völlig der
junge hier sind überall down sind scharf
bekomme ich nicht aussah bekomme ich
nicht aus wolle auch seide
nein nein
oder doch damit das auch gar nicht
auffällt migration abkommen das auch
okay nein bekomme ich nicht wirklich
sind diese piratenschiffe übrigens
klatscht das ding ist die piraten können
ja nicht selber wieder hochklettern und
die lassen sich von mir einfach ins
wasser schubsen und dann können wir ja
wat die kiste das hat mich entschieden
zu tun
das kann doch nicht sein dass ich das
ist jetzt daran liegt dass ich keinen
string habe drei karten 3 teilt apple
helmut gefunden ist das denn
hör gut dann finde ich jetzt wohl kein
string so ich brauche echt alter da
kommst ringo starr kommt string haus ja
ich hab's springs gefunden ich hab mich
für meinen chocobos sattel
so hat noch nicht daheim
nein ich brauche einfach strings
die gesamte kraft wann dann kann man
sich in sat 1 einköpfen chocobo sattel
sogar nur ja und ich kann dir sogar eine
feder hut bringen sollte eine feder
mitbringt von einem schoko ja wer cool
das ist die goldene feder dann kannst du
dir auch ein sattel machen kann ich ja
klar wie man strebe macht und du
erklärst man group co trainer wird so
co-trainer wieder lieder so gut
irgendwie habe ich alle verarscht die
meinten ja ich hab sofort vorbeugungs
tisch okay leute jetzt geht's ab und
zwar welches chocobo nehmen wir nehmen
wir das da vorne unter den hier nehme
wir nehmen das da vorne würde ich sagen
das ist auf jeden fall nicht immer aus
holosko ok kriegt den schoko okay es
erst er er liebt mich ich kann nicht
erhaben schoko kija berlin tokio oder
habt ihr besseren namen könnt ihr
einfach mal in die kommentare schreiben
wie soll ich den nennen das mammut ich
dachte gerade das wären das wären ränder
fehler in der welt dass es so eine
idealistin wir haben gut ein mammut
erfolg etwas ist das ich traue mich
nicht da hinzugehen das sieht einfach so
aus wie fünf kühe zusammen und meinte
boos richtig es hat richtig angst meint
okubo fällt erstmal eine höhle reinigt
ob das ist richtig betrunken in tokio wo
das wort ist voll komisch chocobo da wir
so einen stripclub alter mofa klar dass
alles geht hier ja in mainz auch nicht
so komisch oki doki und ist es hat so
dass es so süß das hat so aber das hat
so ein regenbogen camp irgendwie als
irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht was diese
mögliche zeuge gibt nichts zu holen
hinten sind noch diamanten also
eigentlich heute so viel voran kommen
quasi nur mehr gefahren haben den schoko
geholt und findet jetzt schon wieder
diamanten und diesen leuten jetzt auch
sicherheitshalber an kleinen taschen
machen bei rechten ganz schnell die
diamanten ab und ist permanent okubo
irgendwo ein macho gescheckten hat in
der wand fest
ich stelle mich einfach auf dem baum war
dies kann so erwarte ich noch ganz kurz
die eben dass man schoko bahrain
parkinson haus rein nicht dass er mir
noch irgendwie abhanden kommt hier das
dauert ja nicht mehr lange so viel zeit
muss sein das muss jetzt an ihnen machen
jetzt nämlich für festung weil ich ja
sofort fertig ihm recht weit weg aber
leute werden die folge aus der wenn ihr
die vollgas der perspektive von cash
sehen wollt könnt ihr einfach auf
skepsis kanal gehen da ist ein eisbär
ein polarbär direkt vor uns endlich auch
für mich wenn ihr lukas 16 volt er macht
eine schöne reise ja schaut euch mal vor
webber vorbei pipapo so in der nächsten
folge werde ich dann mit dem kobo hier
rausgehen wahrscheinlich und dann die
diamant abfahren und alles und schreibt
mir nahmen die kommentare treppe wohl
denn meine hunde seien könnten diesen
weg peter baust einfach weg na gut fast
jedem zweiten spiel was zu finde ich
auch es gibt einen zweiten außer dem
gift mega spinne und dann sehen wir uns
einfach bei der nächsten folge bleibt
geile macht's gut besucht